MCP or modified citrus pectin is referenced in your cancer book as an important supplement to take
to help prevent metastasis. I've already had my lung cancer metastasis once. Would this be a good
addition for my supplement protocol? Well, modified citrus pectin would not be contraindicated for anybody.
So yes, you could add modified citrus pectin to your protocol. Now, a couple downsides with modified
citrus pectin. We have some people that are taking it and are putting it right in their smoothie
with the other things that they have in their smoothie, whatever it is and blending it and
drinking it that way. That seems to work well. If you're going to take modified citrus pectin
the powder and you're going to take it separate from a smoothie, the water it is, it doesn't dissolve
in water really at all and you're going to get frustrated. It does dissolve instantly in a little
orange juice. Orange juice is a lot of sugar. Yeah, but if you just do three ounces of orange juice,
put your modified citrus pectin. It'll dissolve and make it thicker, but then you'll be able to
go up that down if you're not taking it with a smoothie. It's best to put it in orange juice. I know
some people have put it with some lemon juice or some lemonade. It has to be like a citrus juice
in order for it to absorb well. If you read the literature, the literature that I've read
written about modified citrus pectin in a perfect scenario, you're taking it more on an empty stomach
with some orange juice, but we also realize that it's really hard to live in a perfect scenario. I
talk to people all the time that are like, it's really hard for me to split my supplements up
three times a day. Life gets in the way, so it's difficult to stay on a protocol where you're taking
that on a relatively empty stomach and you've got so many other different pieces of your protocol. It's
hard to stay motivated, especially if you're doing well to stick to something like that. So I've
always told people just go ahead and it's easier. Just put it in your smoothie. It's just going to be
easier to do it. Still going to get 99% of the benefit of it. But is there anything wrong with somebody
adding modified citrus pectin that I didn't tell them to add? No, everybody can add that there's no
down side to that.